δυνμης δηλαδή μια μεγάλης δύναμης της της κεντροδεξιας και με δού την τη λογική ένα
αρμόζουν πράματα ενέργειες πάνως το μιτρό απλώμεδούτε ηλογική εγώ οι φιλοσοφία μου διαφορετική σε τουν
το θέμα είχε να κάνει με το ανεδιαυρώνετον το μήνυμα νέα δεν εδιαυρονεδού ας πούμε
να μερώτας και αποδεικμίεσμο ότι διαυρόνεται το μήνυμα που εν το καταλάβω εγώ τι λα
διαν έχω κάτη με όω θαντιων τωνιο άνο εγώ έθα τουλλουν ότι κύρικάνις λάθος να
με επειδί θα μέιο που ήταν κυβέρνηση λαλο του δαν που μεκπου που είμαστα κυβέρνηση
και γραφά α ου αναστασιάδη του όποιοδήποτε ότι κάμρις λάθος επιεμέλως του κόμπατες θα θα
του πω έναντίον του επιδενει υπουργός τορα κάποιο αν είναι αλλά μου επιθες τανα σου
πω εξηγάς κοινωνίας ότε ναι έτσι αυτή είναιδική μο φιλοσοφία για τοτον το θέμα οποίαυ
τ οωπική είαπο θενούσυςν εργαλές πλέο της προεδρομοαερμο θεωρίς μιχάλημεότικάπκι σε σαγωγικά την περιμένου στη
γνία τοπέ περιμενε α διαχωρίσουμε λέίωίσε π τους τεούς τς εργάζες τις ανίδας είμαι που
τους τενούςστις εργαλες τς ανίδας και τουλιάμετα α ότι δική μου απσναι ακαι ανίδα η
δουλειά σε ίναι να παίρνεταις δικές τις απόφασης θέλω ότοτο ν ξεκαθαρίσω για να με
ιπάι ώρις μεαπράτα πριν εψήβζαναντίο και τα ιά τι δική μου απόψωψη την άποψη μου
την οοα ν ύπα της προεδρού την οοία νακρινε ότι να ακολουθήσει κατί που εκριόαι
να ακολουθήσ σμέι πλαδή ούτε ούτε ποτέ σχέση μας ήταν ότι ξέργω επιθέλω να την
επρεάσω να καειζιο που πιστεύκο καθένας έσι τη θέση να σ πηράσει κινις το ότιό
ούτε π ούτε επαρχι έτσι προσπάθειασε καθανανοσταά νικόν πο έχειεση θεωρείς κάποιοι περιμένω τη στη
γωνιά ν ικάγρησες αισαγωγικά δεν παεικαλά το πω έη όλους τους προδρους λους όλους τους
προέδρους η θέση του προεδρο μοναχική να σ οποιο δήποτε οργανς